Six months since the Taliban seized power
and the killing and other human rights abuses
have gone on multiplying.
Women have been a major target – their peaceful
protests broken up, some have been threatened,
beaten and disappeared.
The Taliban had promised an inclusive government.
But not a single woman was appointed to the
cabinet.
My guest this week from Kabul is Shafiullah
Azam, Taliban director general of economic
relations at the foreign ministry.
“Are you and the Taliban capable of anything
more constructive than violence and repression?”
“We are working on our police forces, before
they were warriors for 20 years but after
that they changed the role from warriors to
policemen.”
But what future are they building?
Sources tell DW that the drug trade is booming
and the Taliban is still taking its cut, as
it has done for years.
And will they crackdown on some of the world’s
most dangerous terror groups, openly hosted
in the country.
Do they really believe they can play nice
with Al Qaida and the West at the same time?
That and much more on Conflict Zone.
Shafiullah Azam welcome to Conflict Zone.
Nice to be with you.
The Taliban made a lot of promises when it
seized power last August, and they've broken
a lot of them.
Is there any reason why the world should trust
anything they say these days?
We know a Taliban made or Islamic Emirate
made many promises, but based on their five
or six months' experience, if we see the changes,
actually it's totally dramatic to not only
to foreigners but as well to Afghans, and
for 20 years, many propaganda has been made
against Islamic Emirate.
But while they come to the power and they
clearly show that to everyone, that these
were rumors, fake news and propaganda.
Alright Mr. Azam, let me just, pick you up
on that, because you said they have been,
rightly, in power for almost a year, almost
half a year.
The UN and other human rights bodies continue
to release deeply disturbing reports of their
human rights violations.
Aren't you ashamed of that?
Before this report, a representative of UN
had a meeting with the interior minister,
and they said they showed their satisfaction
from security and to all members of the UN
as well.
On 6 February, we had a meeting with UN, all
organizations, which are UNAMA, and they showed
their satisfaction from the current new government
that they provided well security to all of
UN members, then that they have access to...
Apart from UN members, your officials claimed
repeatedly there were amnesties for those
who worked for the previous government.
And yet the UN has revealed credible evidence
that your fighters have gone on hunting down
and killing those who've already surrendered.
The UN said just two months ago that between
August and November last year, they received
evidence of more than 100 killings of former
Afghan security personnel and others associated
with the government.
72 of those killings attributed to the Taliban.
In several cases, the bodies of those victims
were publicly displayed.
How do you justify those crimes attributed
directly to the Taliban?
One thing should be considered: that since
six month, or at least if we want to compare
the situation, there should be some indicators
to compare that with the previous.
In a previous regime, each single day, we
were losing around 300 Afghans in both sides.
That's not a fair comparison.
I'm talking about what you've done since you
came to power.
I'm coming to that.
Based on policy level, there is a clear amnesty
to everyone.
Yes, we can accept it that now we are not
carrying heritage of 20 years' war.
But now, right now, we are carrying heritage
of 43-year war.
Yes, in some cases there would be some incidents
of violation, but it doesn't mean it's a policy
of the government.
Government is following those cases and everyone
would be brought to justice.
So your fighters are out of control.
Is this what you're telling me?
Your fighters are out of control?
No, no, no, no.
I can clearly see that our fighters...
... well either you order these killings or
the fighters are out of control, which is
it?
Our fighters are under control.
If they were not, we would be witness of hundreds
of killings in Afghanistan.
You know better, in 20 years, many wrong things
happen to everyone.
There would be many private cases between
different parties.
But this is, it shows commitment of the government
and for the rest of these violations government
have a full commitment and they will bring
them to justice.
How do we know that?
How do we know?
We only have your word for that?
As far as your justice is concerned, we have
no idea.
There's no independent monitoring of that.
So we only have your word for this.
No, no.
One thing is that the international community
expectation is totally high.
They are not considering the current situation.
We are not living in a Western country that
was calm for hundreds of years.
Still, we move from a conflict zone to to
this, to the peace, to the
stability.
Yes, there would be some stability, but this
is a positive point that government have a
full commitment for that.
And still they have control many cases...
Mr. Azam, you are only being measured, you're
only being measured by the promises that you've
made, not by any other standards and you've
broken a lot of those promises.
As recently as last month, the United Nations
reported credible allegations of illegal disappearances
and said a growing number of the Taliban's
political opponents are being detained, along
with civil society representatives and people
who voice dissent.
Children are also being detained indefinitely.
You think that's fair?
You think that's just?
Right now, if you see, if you compare the
propaganda going against Islamic Emirate,
now we have free press everywhere.
Everyone has their own voices.
Yes, in some cases there would be some investigation
regarding something.
One thing is clear: in every government and
every country, there is a rule for freedom
of speech, for protest, for everything.
Everyone have a right to raise their voice
and protest.
But they should not disrespect values of the
whole country, and they should not do an action
to lead a country to destabilization.
Stability for current government is a priority.
We are going toward stability to bring security
in our country and to the region and to international
community.
Yes, in some cases, in some cases, the government
has a right to investigate from everyone.
To bring everyone to the justice.
This is a right.
But one thing is clear in policy level: that
Afghan current government is completely committed
to the freedom of press.
As they mentioned recently.
They declared in a statement, just requested
from the media and for all users of that,
they should consider.
Mr. Azam, you talk about, you talk about the
freedom of the press.
Since August, more than 6,000 journalists
have lost their jobs.
80% of female journalists are no longer working.
You've closed more than 40% of the media outlets
in the country.
Instead of press freedom, this looks as though
you're scared of the truth.
What makes you and the Taliban so scared of
the truth?
Mr. Sebastian, you are a person that you are
completely aware from Afghan current situation.
These journalists, which they have lost their
job, this is not because the policy level
or the policy of Afghan government.
Let’s look at the policy.
Let's look at the policy.
We have your new journalism code.
Media outlets are told they must prepare,
quote, "detailed reports in coordination with
the government media and information center."
Why?
So you can censor the stories.
Is that the aim?
This coordination doesn't mean that they should
hide the realities.
This coordination mean that everything should
be based on rules and regulation, based on
the rules of journalism.
In some cases, in some cases we have seen
that many are making propaganda because of
their personal interests to get asylum.
Just control on these issues is important
for the government and from everywhere.
Right now, we are requesting from media and
many
other activities just they should reflect
what is really going on on the ground, not
what they are imagining.
So show respect, you show respect, do you,
for freedom of the press and for journalists?
This wasn't on show last September, when journalists
covering demonstrations were rounded up, and
photos later showed the backs of two reporters
covered with bruises and gashes from being
whipped with cables by your thugs.
Does that sound respectful to you?
One thing should be clear.
Listen to me.
Why you are totally differentiat[ing] Afghan
government from the other side of the other
countries?
The same incident, same thing can happen in
Western countries as well.
We have many videos that show how police of
western European countries, the US, they are
treating women.
Their behavior is so brutal against them.
Mr. Azam, we are not talking about other countries,
we are talking about Afghanistan...
... the problem, the problem...
You can play the "what about” game indefinitely.
"What about" other places?
I'm talking to you about Afghanistan.
That's it.
If any behavior is not suitable to be done
with the protesters or many other activists,
it doesn't mean that we are happy, government
is happy on that.
Yes, but in a ground, something can happen
and it's common everywhere.
But the problem is, why some TV channels some
groups of countries they are, they made Afghanistan
under watch.
They are broadcasting very small issues in
a very wide manner.
This is a problem.
Let's come to the reality, to the neutrality.
Consider current situation of every country
[and] based on that, make calculation against
them.
We're talking about your country and the concerns
being expressed at what is going on in your
country from the highest level.
The U.N. secretary-general said last month
he remained extremely concerned about the
fate of several women activists who have been
abducted from their homes and have disappeared.
No Afghan, he said, should live in fear of
a knock at their door in the night, and no
family should be left to wonder about the
whereabouts and fate of their loved ones.
But they are living in fear, aren't they?
And creating that fear seems to have been
your primary achievement over the last half-year.
Are you in the Taliban capable of anything
more constructive than violence and repression?
Because we've seen a lot of that from you?
My point is this that every comment or claims,
which is made on current government, just
compare that to the previous government which
used … and they were glorifying that we
are making good governance here.
Compared to that...
I know you want to talk about the other government,
but we're talking about your government.
...these types of incidents was happening
on that time as well.
: We're talking about your government.
… at that time as well.
Right now, right now...
I know you want to change the subject...
I do not.
I not reject that that there would be no mistake.
Sure.
Everything can happen everywhere.
But based on policy level, it's not the policy.
The current government within five months,
they control many many better compared to
the previous regime.
This is achievement.
No one is exposing this type of achievement.
Just they are making criticize.
In some thing there would be some violations.
We accept that there is some personal cases,
some personal behavior.
Right now, we are working on our police forces
— before they were warriors for 20 years.
But after that they changed the role of warrior
to the policemen.
Right now, every single day, if you ask from
Kabul citizen or many other citizens all over
the country, there is a positive movement.
We have many progress in this situation.
They provided well security to every Afghan,
to foreigners, which they are here.
It's unacceptable to everyone compared to
the propaganda.
And a lot of concern being expressed at high
level, Mr. Azam.
The UN sees a pattern in the Taliban's behavior.
It talks of arbitrary arrests and detentions,
as well as torture and ill treatment of civil
society activists, journalists and media workers,
along with former government and security
forces personnel.
That adds up to a pretty shameful record,
doesn't it?
This is not in a level that they are expressing
that.
In some cases, I accept that there would be
some problems, but it doesn't shows the policy
level.
In some cases, there are some groups are making
some videos, they are making some propaganda.
I can give you an example of that.
Right now, Afghan government didn’t force
no one, no woman to wear a burqa.
They let them just decide as an advice, that
[you should] adjust yourself based on Islamic
and Afghan value.
But in some cases, some are coming [and] they
are burning burqa.
What does it mean?
Actually, this is an act of destabilizing.
They are bringing pressure on police that
to show an action and to make a propaganda
on that.
Let me just make this point to you.
You say nobody is being forced to wear the
hijab or the burqa.
That's simply not true.
On February the 7th General Mubeen Khan, spokesman
for your Kabul Police, said "it's not up to
the people to say we choose the coverings
we like.
No, you do what we prescribe.
Period.
You do what we prescribe."
And he added, "the Taliban's patience is running
thin."
So Mr. Azam, they are being forced and told
what to wear, contrary to your comfortable
assurances.
If it is right, right now, ask from your reporters,
and they should see Kabul's situation, other
cities' situation, so why, this is not physical
existence, what you are claiming?
Actually, this is not a policy.
Don't make an excuse of one person as a policy
— policy is totally different.
Right now Afghan government encourages everyone...
He is the police spokesman for Kabul, he's
the Kabul police spokesman.
He's not.
He's a police spokesperson.
Maybe because of such claims, which is not
representing policy of Afghan government policymakers
or others.
And there are others which are implementing
the rules.
Right now, the situation which is provided
within this …, this is totally unexpected.
And Afghan government is working to regularize
all activities to bring that type of facilities,
services to Afghans, which they are in need
of that, that meet their religious and cultural
values.
This is a very positive change.
And the women, and the women, the way women
are being treated, is not a positive change.
The fact is they've become second class citizens
— pushed around, forced to wear what you
decide.
Study where you decide.
Work where you decide, if at all.
Can you give an example?
What gives you what gives you the right?
I'll give you an example, and I'll give you
what the UN secretary-general said about this
just last month.
He said women scientists, lawyers and teachers
are locked out, locked out, wasting skills
and talents that will benefit the entire country.
A generation of girls is seeing its hopes
and dreams shattered.
How does destroying the girls' hopes and dreams
fit into your Islamic code?
Please answer that.
This is not correct.
Right now...
So the UN secretary-general doesn't know what
he's talking about.
Is that it?
Listen to me.
I'm not talking about him.
Let's discuss about the fact.
I am requesting you do not rely only on reports.
You can see the current reality which is going
on right now.
University doors are open to the girls.
Why you, why you are not reflecting this positive
signals right now in Jalalabad, or in those
areas which have a hot season right now, women
are going there right now.
Male and, man and woman, they are registering
their names to the concours, which the entrance
door to the university.
Right now, they're registering.
Why you are not discussing about this right
now, we have more than 15,000 women working
only in health sector.
Right now women are working in our passport
directorate, in our identity card directorate,
in Kabul airport or many other areas.
Yes, there were some projects, some, some
other organizations.
The only blame cannot refer to the Taliban.
International donors, they had many economic
projects.
They had many other projects.
They cut their donation.
Therefore, men and women…
Are women going to be welcomed back to all
the jobs they had before?
No, there isn't even a women's ministry anymore
because you closed that down.
In many countries, there is no ministry for
women.
It doesn't mean that the current government
ignoring them, right now before I gave many
example in many ministries, in many organization,
they are doing work.
They are providing services to men and women.
There is no policy for that.
Let's talk about the terrible food shortages,
the humanitarian crisis facing your country,
what has become a daily nightmare for people
trying to feed their families.
It wasn't until the first week of this month
that your first deputy prime minister called
on government departments to present plans
for tackling the crisis.
What have you been doing for the last six
months?
Regarding humanitarian aid, there was a concern
for many years that takeover by coming Islamic
Emirate, we will lose values of 20 years'
achievements.
Right now Afghan government kept that system
active.
It's [the] international community — they
are ignoring the system, they are destroying.
They are making a parallel system which is
difficult for them.
Difficult for them to distribute the humanitarian
assets or many others.
They are ignoring banking system.
Mr Azam, let's talk about the enormous illegal
drug trade in Afghanistan that the Taliban
has warned that this huge criminal enterprise
will have to stop.
Does that also apply to the Taliban as well,
since they've been cashing in on the drugs
trade in parts of Afghanistan for a very long
time?
Are they going to stop trading in illegal
narcotics as well?
Come to, come to the policy.
Right now all narcotic business or trade is
going through our … banking system.
Right now, Afghan government is totally committed
for re-establishing supporting banking system.
But sanctions happened...
I'm talking about the drug business.
I'm asking whether your own fighters are going
to stop dealing in drugs and taking taxes
from it.
Last year, a report to the UN Security Council
said the production and trafficking of drugs
remained the Taliban's largest single source
of income.
Again, how does that fit in with your Islamic
principles?
These reports were available as well about
the previous government as well, but you can
say the policy of Afghan current government
in their previous period, which they have
a government, how they brought that this business
to zero.
You're not answering my question.
Right now, I can say the situation would be
many, many better from a government which
was supported by US, NATO.
I can clearly guarantee that.
I can clearly guarantee.
Right now, Afghan government is working to
provide alternative in agricultural section.
If international community relieved their
concerns, they should support our agriculture
section.
There would be no business.
There would be no harvesting of narcotics.
Can we, can we also...
Policy is clear.
If international community is real about their
concern, they should support our agricultural
sector.
Mr Azam, can we expect the Taliban will also
fail to keep its promise to prevent terrorist
groups in your country from launching attacks
outside Afghanistan?
You are still very friendly with al Qaida.
Your two groups have even intermarried.
Many of the leaders are
based in Afghanistan and the border region.
How exactly do you intend to prevent them
launching attacks?
Clear example is available.
Compared to the previous report, always they
were criticizing that more than 20 terrorist
groups are active in Afghanistan.
Actually, these groups rise and born under
U.S., NATO forces.
But regarding Daesh forces, while Islamic
Emirate was at the same time in fighting against
previous Afghan regime use NATO forces, they
proved that they eliminated Daesh from all
over the country.
This was Afghan government.
This was international community, many reports
of...
We're talking about Al Qaida.
I clearly said, based on Doha agreement, Afghan
current government have a full commitment.
There would be no threat to Afghans.
They will not allow every single group to
make a threat to other countries.
This is a full commitment.
But you allow them to train on your territory.
You allow them to train on your territory.
The UN report recently said that under your
rule, these terrorists enjoy greater freedom
in Afghanistan than at any time in recent
history, and there are no signs you've taken
steps to limit their activities.
Why?
Totally baseless.
Totally incorrect.
So they just don't understand what they are
talking about.
I'm confused.
I'm confused about these UN reports.
While their representatives are coming and
they are discussing with our Ministry of Interior,
Ministry of Defense, they are saying, well
security is provided, well situation in everywhere.
But on the other side, those reporters, I
don't know who are there from where they are
receiving this type of reports.
Clearly, I can say this is the policy of current
government: We want to make a stable country
instead of conflict zone.
We are going to the zone of national interest,
to the zone of economic interest.
We want to reconnect a big project of our
neighbors and regional.
This is the policy.
At the same time, with this policy, we cannot
support those groups which are making threats
to others.
Yes, there are many heritage from 20 years.
Afghan government is fighting against them
and we will provide a secure environment for
all investors.
You want, you want a secure environment.
You want a secure environment and a stable
country by hosting some of the most dangerous
terrorist groups in the world.
You think the West is going to watch you and
expect you to play nice with those terrorist
groups and with them at the same time?
You really think the West is going to accept
that?
That's totally rejected by Afghan government.
They called on them to please instead of blaming,
making excuses, provide a proof to the government.
Based on that, if government didn't take action,
they can claim on that.
For 20 to 30 years, there was a huge propaganda
against Afghan government.
Let's, if we want to have a stable country,
and to not be a threat to the neighbor, to
the region and country, let's support Afghan
government.
They have a
good plan for our region, for Afghanistan.
Main focus is economic development in Afghanistan.
Let's support.
Let's give a chance.
Alright.
Shafiullah Azam, thanks very much for being
on Conflict Zone.
Thank you.
Appreciate your time.
It's my pleasure.
Thank you so much.